أعلنت الولايات المتحدة والمملكة العربية السعودية الآن أن
الفصيلين المتحاربين في السودان
قد اتفقا على بدء محادثات أولية
في جدة في الساعات المقبلة.
وقف إطلاق النار وإنهاء
الصراع الآن أدى العنف إلى
مقتل مئات الأشخاص
وإصابة آلاف آخرين ، أخبر موظف طبي رفيع المستوى نقله
إلى مستشفى في ولاية حرتوم لشبكة
CNN أن القوات شبه العسكرية تحاول
السيطرة على المستشفيات لاستخدامها
كقواعد للعمليات ولحماية
قواتها.  القوات من الضربات الجوية التي
ورد أنها استولت بالفعل على أكبر
مستشفى للولادة في البلاد
تقول الأمم المتحدة إن أكثر من
مائة وعشرين ألف شخص
فروا من السودان منذ اندلاع القتال في
منتصف أبريل / نيسان ، وحثت وكالة اللاجئين التابعة للأمم المتحدة
البلدان المجاورة على إبقاء الحدود
مفتوحة من أجل  مدنيون يفرون من العنف
دعا الرئيس الكيني إلى
إنهاء فوري للقتال خلال
اجتماع مع المستشار الألماني
ويليام روتو حث الغرب على المساعدة في
إنهاء العنف الذي أضفته إلى
عروض المستشارة لاستخدام صوته
وتأثير ألمانيا في
منصات مختلفة بما في ذلك  توقع الاتحاد الأوروبي لمجموعة الدول السبع G20
والأمم المتحدة أن تحظى باهتمام عالمي
بشأن الصراع المنسي في إفريقيا
بشكل عام في إطار خاص في القرن
الأفريقي ،
وصلت عدة طائرات تابعة للصليب الأحمر إلى
السودان يوم الجمعة محملة بالأغذية
والإمدادات الطبية التي تمس الحاجة إليها ، حيث
تسبب الصراع في
أزمة إنسانية.  مع مجموعات الإغاثة التي تناشد للحصول على
مساعدات فورية